and right now the Associated Press is
just given the check mark to Rafael
Warnock he's going back to the U.S
Senate as the winner of this runoff
against Herschel Walker right now at
50.4 percent to Walker's 49.6 Rafael
Warnock has won the runoff in Georgia
four weeks after we held the midterms in
2022 which in effect Lara gives you the
balance of power now in the Senate
Democrats at 51 Republicans at 49
majority is 51 and that's where the
Democrats have reached this means
essentially that Kamala Harris will not
have to break any tie-breaking votes uh
this means an effect that on the
committee votes you know when you have
legislation that's on the margins
Democrats and Joe Biden will have a
slight Edge after this victory tonight
Bill Hammer I'd like to say this is uh
but it's not
this is what we expected and you know
look the Senate Democrats I would argue
uh did a much better job and they got
the early vote out and Brian Kemp gave
his list and did a late night kind of
video call but
I mean I gotta have the operation in
effect uh as always
um guys uh we appreciate it Bill uh stay
with us all right
um we have more
all right we're not going anymore we
gotta go into Molly Hemingway sorry I
have a whole script in front of me Molly
Hemingway and of course kellyanne Conway
Molly
you and I talked about this about a week
ago we felt this coming
to me it never felt like the Senate
Republicans wanted this guy
in office
he was a trump pick they didn't like
that they probably like him as a person
Herschel as a person but there wasn't
the intensity on the part of the
Republicans as there was on the part of
the Democrats I felt it you felt it
but we don't change anything we have the
same people in place in leadership same
people in place apparently at the RNC
that's not perhaps that's not changing
we just keep doing the same thing over
and over again I'm pissed tonight
frankly go ahead yeah it's really
offensive I'm mad for Republican voters
for Republican donors who have put so
much into having some wins and they just
see kind of failure across the board
there aren't people who are working on
early voting or banking ballots there's
no clear messaging I mean you look at
what happened since the midterm
elections where you had a senate that
basically responded to those
disappointing midterm losses by doing
nothing other than sabotaging their own
base what is the case for voting
Republican for the Senate after these
midterms I don't think one was even
attempted to be made and yeah nothing
seems to be changing but you didn't see
a lot of enthusiasm down there of course
the spending was completely yeah it was
just look at how close it was though I
mean what did we say this was winnable
Kelly and I know you don't want any
chain you want Ronald McDaniel I like
Ronald McDaniel
this like a warning sign flashing are we
just going to keep doing the same thing
all over again every single election
Kevin McCarthy won the house he won the
house yes he did and we were out spent
three to one here why no excuse there's
no excuse in Georgia for us not to have
done what Brian Kemp did yes he's the
incumbent Governor he's very popular
he's running against Stacey Abrams but
he turned out over his micro targeting
plan his Grassroots people and I guess
at Mitch McConnell's group funded it but
they did that in the last couple of days
ago did Mitch McConnell he could have
won that seat outright four weeks ago we
wouldn't have had to have her run off
her walker could have won I think it was
one of the most improved candidates of
the cycle we had some Duds of candidates
this time he was out there working hard
but we need to not just compete for
votes for ballots we need to compete for
ballots if we don't Bank ballots early
we're going to keep this not but we
didn't but we didn't do it in 2020
because everyone said don't vote early
because that's correct not everyone well
I think a lot of people did at the very
top of the Republican party people did
but Molly Mitch McConnell did give 11
million to the effort that's 14 million
to the effort in Georgia but where was
the all hands on deck yet Lindsey Graham
he was there he did a lot every Senator
should have been there every female
senator but why I'm going to ask the
question tonight nobody wants to talk
about this why weren't they down there
Molly I think that if they had needed
this seat to have a majority in the
Senate you actually would have seen the
establishment in DC caring a little bit
about it they obviously didn't care
about it once it wouldn't have mattered
there but also there's an issue of
people talk about giving money to
different races we're very good at
seeing how money can go around to
different people the Republican Party
gives money to Consultants they need to
care more about winning and less about
the means by which races are run
regardless of who takes over the RNC
regardless if Rana continues there need
to be massive systematic changes to the
whole way that races are being handled
the Consultants who are running them
well the Consultants paid and paid
regardless of outcome they do pollsters
Lobby infection pollster I mean
Consultants these people are the only
growth industry left in Washington DC
frankly well I like to say I've been
talking about this for years they're
walking I put it in my book they're
walking recall violation staph infection
candidates often lose Consultants always
win and they're nameless by the way most
of the Consultants who make the most
money and have for decades Laura the
losing Romney race was one billion
dollars and they're on strategies I mean
they're still around people but guess
what nobody even knows who they are in
other words the average donor average
Laura Ingram viewer right now can't name
those people the way they can name Molly
maybe they should be named but by the
way they are nameless but they are not
blameless and the Republicans these are
these people have been recycled from
campaign to campaign to campaign but
there's no accountability yes but
they're going to blame Herschel Walker
tonight they're going to blame Donald
Trump and I just want some facts laid
out here I know Mitch McConnell early on
said he wanted David Perdue or Kelly
Lefler to run against Rapha Doug Collins
would have been they said that she said
that you know from the beginning but
Mitch McConnell endorsed Herschel a long
time ago like this didn't happen
yesterday everybody said they were all
in but we didn't see all the Senators
there where were the other 49 Republican
Senators I don't believe it's just
because it's 49 51.
nobody wants Kamala Harris you breaking
the only thing she ever does is break
ties it's the only progress she's ever
made that doesn't even matter this is
Georgia we should be winning we're about
to see a cram down of this Omnibus Bill
perhaps meaning the Senate leadership
would rather work with Schumer then have
a chance to work with Kevin McCarthy in
the new year that speaks volumes Molly I
know you guys have written about it over
at the Federalist well and talking again
about the the role that Mitch McConnell
plays here Mitch McConnell loved those
candidates uh two years ago they also
lost and so did the Colorado uh you know
we have an issue where the Republican
party needs to think about how it's
winning elections and it is not thinking
about that at all and it talks about
candidate quality Mitch McConnell
sabotaged Republican candidates and the
voters who picked them by saying that
the candidates were bad well we have now
in the Senate a plan for Republicans to
help Chuck Schumer with massive spending
package they're doing nothing to stop it
what about the candidate quality of
these current Senators who don't care
about their base who don't care about
the direction of the country and are
more than happy to work with Democrats
than wait always yes always now I want
to play This Moment from last night with
Kevin McCarthy on the show he had a
piece of advice from Mitch McConnell we
give enormous credit for by the way for
all the judicial nominees he's pushed
through for all the years we huge credit
for that but when it comes to this
Omnibus issue watch this
we're 28 days away from Republicans
having the gavel we would be stronger in
every negotiation so any Republican
that's out there trying to work with
them is wrong why would you wake up does
that include McConnell yes why would you
want to work on anything if we have the
gavel inside Congress you just we have a
stronger yes wait till we're in charge
in the hill today all these unnamed
sources among the Senate senior
leadership and Friends of the the
minority leader well we didn't think
Kevin McCarthy was going to be able to
get anything through so they never go on
the record they never defend the merits
of their position it's always unnamed
sources they never give real interviews
about why this Omnibus is the right way
to go but never will hear from them the
true leakers in Washington I thought
your interview with leader McCarthy was
masterful last night and I thought his
answer was perfect basically they've
been waiting for four years to get the
majority back you can wait another month
everybody could wait for you waited four
years you could wait four weeks and his
whole point was wait for us because we
actually are going to be in the majority
in the house and Lara they they have no
room for excuses and no reason to not
work on the border energy economy
present United States yeah but Kevin no
Kevin you mean absolutely but he look he
invited Joe Biden to the Border that's
not that's not his stunt Joe Biden knows
what's going on at the border he doesn't
care he has been to Delaware 174 days
he's been to the the Border zero days
including today I mean think about this
174 to nothing that's a fact everybody
so and we know fentanyl is the number
one killer in the rest of it so I think
telling Mitch McConnell especially after
tonight when you clearly don't even have
a 50 50 Cent I mean it's like just wait
for us over here in the house what does
it say for 2024. if this is what the
Republican voters see
what does that tell them going into 2024
with all these we have a lot of great
Senate races coming up on in our should
be in our favor is this a way to build
that new Coalition of Hispanics this I
can't imagine how demoralizing this is
and it does also get back to these
policy issues like if you provide any
resistance to what's happening with
Democrat control of the Senate if you
work with the renew Republican majority
in Congress you can actually generate
excitement and enthusiasm for two years
from now when you see when Democrats
take over they come up with like really
extreme policy proposals like packing
the Supreme Court ending the filibuster
it's not even that these things are
going to happen but it's a way of like
moving things in their Direction they
act bold no matter how small their
majority Republicans on the other hand
seem to just accept defeat even when
they have won they are worried about
pushing anything and then it has
electoral consequences well the good
news is we are increasing among these
key groups Hispanics indisputably
African Americans Asian Americans
Suburban white women came through for
republicans we won the national vote but
we really ran up the totals in some of
these rural districts instead of winning
with 52 we won with got to win the
cities
and look but we want in Oregon Virginia
New Jersey that's good news these seats
no doubt so we have to build on those
coalitions but Laura I hate to say we
have to invest in the non-sexy parts of
Politics the ballot act says you got to
bank visual Libras why are we taking a
chance Grandpa can get out of the
bathroom that day let alone the house to
vote get his vote a month in advance why
are we waiting for that
um Molly your reaction to Matt taibi uh
Twitter stream on what was going on with
big Tech and uh this this election so
just a minute Baker and the Jim Baker
angle obviously at Twitter so James
Baker was at the FBI who was implicated
in the Russia collusion hoax he left as
they were investigating some of the
leaks that were happening there he gets
hired at Twitter and we learned today
that he was meddling in the
dissemination of these explosive
um Communications about how Twitter
meddled in the 2020 election by
suppressing the hunter Biden laptop
story and it's just amazing because he
was he was supposed to be a general
counsel for Twitter and if he was
actively working against Twitter and
apparently on behalf of himself and the
FBI this is the type of thing that could
lead to disbarment and it is um I sort
of say Elon Musk got rid of James Baker
which is more than most Republicans did
in the entire Russia occlusion Bingo
ladies couldn't think of two better
people to have on tonight thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else